I want you to answer for me so I got a
question from one of my newsletter
readers Mohammed love you guys wrote in
to say hello Evan I'm seriously
considering entrepreneurship but this
one major question holding me back
should i create a business that i think
will succeed in terms of wealth or
should i create a business that will
revolve around my passion but may not be
practical nor make a lot of money now I
feel like I've answered this question a
lot on this channel and and I could send
Mohammed to one of my older videos I
cover this topic and and I think it it
speaks to how big a problem this is for
a lot of people and how much how much of
a struggle and and stress it is a come
up with a business idea and what to do
at the start but I wanted to have a
little fun with this one what I want you
guys to do believe nation stand-up today
we're going to have some fun I want you
to answer as me I gave you two options
one in the comments below right what do
you think I would say to Mohammed put it
in quotes what the effing quote would be
in the comments below option two if you
really want to rise above if you really
want to get that extra degree of
awesomeness in there and get some free
promotion on my channel make a video
reply you be me responding to Muhammad
and if it's good i'll share it on my
channel so what do you think leave
something below make a video reply I'm
looking forward to it Wow me guys belief
if you want some believe in your inbox
every week to keep you motivated check
out the link below to join my newsletter